як стало зрозуміло сьогодні варіанта у нас
з вами лише два
або владимир зеленський змові з
групою осіб брав участь у злочині
проти з'єднаних штатів Америки чи
він тупий і його втягнули в це
злочин перший це державна
зрада друге це ще гірше давайте про
цьому детальніше
shox його вона мене ведеш прокурор
Володимир зеленський цитата про порошенка
і байдена так я чув не прокоментую
думаю це не останній знак який
побачать українці реагувати має
прокуратура правоохоронні органи
генеральний прокурор України та ще вчора
зареєстрував кримінальне провадження
за заявою депутата деркача
будуть розслідувати я знаю що це може
бути сприйнято кваліфіковано як
державна зрада все до
правоохоронцям кого він мав на увазі
коли говорю про державну зраду
як сьогодні стає зрозуміло себе і
самого деркач а тому що з'єднані
штати сьогодні газ а сам департамент
міністерства фінансів офіційно
оголосили про те, що не наклали санкції
на деяких громадян України та на
деякі компанії в Україні в тому числі
на деркач вона накладена на санкції були ще
раніше в тому числі санкції при накладення
народного депутата фракції партії
слуга народу фракція зеленого
олександра дубинського тут має бути
жарт про тупий собачий рід
але батьки виховали так що в принципі
навіть ніяково але жарт так і проситься
обійдуся без неї втручання в
виборчий процес
вибори президента сполучених штатів це
скандал цей злочин це
дипломатичний провал я про це говорив
ще тоді сьогодні про це говорить
об'єднаних про це говорять об'єднані
штати офіційно на офіційному
рівнів тому що деркач офіційно
згідно з даними з'єднаних штатів
Америки є агентом спецслужб
російської федерації агент спецслужб
кремля і всі ті хто був пов'язаний з цією
операцією проти
як стало відомо вечерею так давно
наступного президента сполучених штатів
байден це було спец операція
втручання у виборчий процес
зганьбити байдина шляхом публікації
предок переговорів порошенка та байдена
деркач
дубинський та ще кілька осіб вугра
громадян України та компанії як
яких є засоби масової
інформації серед яких природно
вас інформації брали участь у цій
спецоперації кремля та зелінський своєї ж
як цитата його-то так само
брав участь у цій спецоперації
володі готуйся ти наступний з'єднані
штати і python сьогодні
наступний президент
не прощають втручання у виборчий
процес і не прощають злочини
щодо сполучених штатів, а не
злопам'ятні вони і злі і пам'ять у
погані і добре б ці санкції були б
спрямовані тільки проти тебе
вони можливо на жаль нашому порушують
дружні стосунки між нашими
країнами і слава богу, що є опозиція
яка нівелює
це і намагаючись на державному рівні
вибудовувати подальше довгострокові
сприятливі взаємовигідні відносини та
співпраця з урядом США
яка ось зараз ось-ось вступить
посада тому що ви або тупі або
злочинці напишіть глядачі що ви про
це думаєте який варіант для вас
найімовірніше це свідоме
злочин чи дурість що ще гірше
і
[музика]